shouldn't rage make you faster ranger
smart weapon
hey guys Joey here and I hope you've all
had a wonderful release week with
injustice too because it's a damn fine
game but hey don't take my word for it
head on over to GameSpot calm and check
out Peter Brown's full review of the
game now if you're anything like me and
your background is mostly in Capcom
fighting games you might find injustice
too just a little bit weird the combo
system is way different from Street
Fighter and there are so many little
mechanics that you might miss when you
first get your hands on the game so what
I've done is I've come up with 6 things
that have helped meet and will hopefully
help you get started in defending or
destroying which everyone you choose the
DC Universe let's get started
so like any fighting game combos are
among the most important things to learn
and injustice to utilizes basic preset
combos that are easily executed by
pressing any combination of light medium
and heavy attack but unlike Street
Fighter these combos don't require
specific timing they're more like target
combos whereas long as the buns are hit
quickly enough they'll still come out
which means the main thing you're gonna
want to practice is linking special
moves afterwards
now not all basic combos will allow you
to do that but once you find the right
ones you'll be doing some heavy damage
in no time there's also one more big
difference between injustice and other
fighting games when using jumping
attacks there's actually no need to wait
until you land before pressing the next
button so for example once the jumping
attack hits you can start inputting the
rest of the combo even before you hit
the ground again timing is crucial to
get this one right but hey practice
makes perfect
one of the more unique things about
injustice games are the environmental
objects you can wall up your opponent
with any time you're close to an object
that you can interact with you'll see it
glow and the small icon will pop up near
your health bar indicating that it's
time to smash an alligator over their
head now different characters will
interact with objects in different
weights bigger buffer characters will
usually grab the object and throw it at
your opponent while smaller more agile
characters will leap off of it kind of
like an extra wall Djem while it is
pretty satisfying to just grab the
object and whack them with it with the
right position you can actually
incorporate the environments into your
combos themselves and of course don't
forget about stage transitions hitting
your opponent with back-heavy near the
edge of specific stages will trigger the
transition resulting in a nice cutscene
and a good chunk of damage and yes you
can cancel a combo into a wall bounce
for the same effect
with so many fighters on the roster
injustice to gives you a ton of
different fighting styles to choose from
now the question is which one's for you
my advice would be to ask yourself how
you like to play but if you're looking
for personal recommendations here are my
thoughts aggressive players who liked
even the pressure are in luck since many
of the characters are pretty capable of
doing that
Superman Batman lead the way here being
two of the most balanced and powerful
characters but Wonder Woman cheetah
Robin and the flash can all rush down
with the best of them if you enjoy
projectiles and controlling space
between your opponent's Brainiac Green
Arrow and dr. fate will pretty much do
just that if you like getting close and
tossing your opponent's around both Bane
and swampthing will satisfy your
grappler needs and for those of you who
just want to mess with your opponents
with high lows and cross ups I suggest
Harley Quinn or a Supergirl but if
you're feeling particularly nasty
Captain cold is the way to go the
icicles that he can shoot onto the
ceiling which then drop down presents
some great options for wake ups
if you find yourself getting stuck in
combos more often than you'd like the
clash mechanic is probably where you'll
find the most help when you're on your
second health bar holding forward and
the meter burn button while gain hit
will prompt a small cutscene between you
and your opponent and you'll be able to
wager your meter to stop their combo and
heal yourself a little now this is where
true mind games come in because if you
have more meter you could bet at all to
make sure you win or you could try to
bet less and save your meter with the
idea being that your opponent will know
they'll lose anyway and not bet anything
but then they might know that and then
bet more yeah there's a lot of circular
reasoning going on here but you get the
idea basically more meter equals good
no you can leave the bowling pins at
home for this one I'm talking about
juggling with combos here arguably the
most crucial part of in Justices combo
system is the juggle which happens when
you hit your opponents in the air and
have the opportunity to continue the
combo some moves like back and forth
heavy will cause huge bounces giving you
a better chance of juggling but each
character has a bunch of moves that will
juggle as well basically it's all about
linking together the right chain to keep
them in the air it'll definitely take
some time and practice but there's
nothing more satisfying than landing
that perfect combo to take off half
their life using meter burns with their
special moves is a great way to extend
combos and pile on some extra damage but
it can take some time to get used to a
lot of the moves in the game require you
to press the meter burn button right
after a move connects so it can be hard
to do on reaction but that's not the
only way you can use a meter per if
you're in the middle of a combo string
pressing down forward or down back and
meter bird will cancer a combo into a
ground or wall bounce giving you that
chance to get in way more damage but
meter burn is also a great defensive
tool as well with enough meter you can
use it to push block execute a full
screen roll or even pop yourself out of
the middle of a combo the game requires
a bunch of resource management so choose
your meter burns wisely unless you be
caught in a deadly combo with no way out
[Applause]
so those are six things that really
helped me and learning the combo system
and mechanics and justice but if you
have any other tips for people just
starting out leave them in the comments
because I would love to hear some more
strategies combo ideas and anything that
could help me and everyone else just get
better at the game so if you want to see
more injustice videos like this one make
sure to hit that subscribe button and
I'll see you guys next time
[Music]